A double security fence
surrounds a 105 foot
diameter flat concrete
platform.
And a close analysis of
the approach road reveals
This is no ordinary
structure.
Where the road comes in
to the compound.
The shadows really give
the impression that the
road doesn't stay flat,
but actually dips down.
Is this compound hiding
secrets that are somehow
related to a more
sinister purpose.
Military analyst Carlos
Munoz finds some historic
images that seem to
confirm that this rural
landscape conceals a
terrifying secret.
The remote location, the
security perimeter, what
looks like an
underground bunker.
It is the launch site
for a nuclear missile.
Declassified military
records confirm this
location was one of a
series of top secret
bunkers.